[music]
when we return home, I would like to
see more modern equipment in our schools,
and it would also be good if the
school introduced a subject that I saw in
Poland. It is about the future path of a
person, choosing a profession and studying
in the next 6 months, I can't at all
there is nothing to say, because the war is always going on,
so no one knows what will happen even tomorrow,
a year from now, maybe the war will already be over.
I
believe that Ukraine will begin to rebuild,
schools, educational institutions and
other
things will begin, and in 5 years, maybe even all
this will end and we will remember  about the
war as just a terrible dream, I
believe that Ukraine will have very good
relations with other countries of the European
Union and the world as a whole.
I hope that the reconstruction and reconstruction
will not only be the best for the people of Ukraine,
but the situation will be even better than it was before
[music]